[Musique]
m
q
usa
[Musique]
oui
ça fait quoi que
[Musique]
vous
la part toujours
[Musique]
ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gun frontier une terre sauvage sans foi
ni loi qui s'étend à l'infini elle ne
laisse aucune chance aux rêveurs et à
ceux à qui manque la force et le courage
c'est une terre sacrée pour les hommes
leurs amis sont mises à rude épreuve et
beaucoup pleurent des larmes de sang au
milieu de ses terres inhospitalières se
dresse une ville lieu de rendez-vous des
affaires et des plaisirs sont en gamme
frontières bonjour l'ami j'aimerais me
débarrasser de cette arme que même en
donner vous 500 pour vous moquer de moi
c'est pas assez à l'époque où je devais
acheter elle m'a coûté 1000 $ 1000 $ et
vous avez acheté ça il y a longtemps
brillé à l'époque où j'étais jeune ça
fait maintenant environ 38 ans au voyeur
je vous en donne 500 fait beaucoup de
mal avec ce fusil j'ai tué de nombreux
hommes aujourd'hui j'ai décidé d'arrêter
de change de vie et des mois repartir du
bon pied prêté mois cet argent vous me
prenez pour quoi pour un pauvre crétin
je suis un commerçant avant tout par un
organisme de charité
prenez votre vieux fusil et fichez moi
le camp je ne fais pas d'affaires avec
les vagabonds et les pouilleux de votre
espèce dégager de ma boutique les dents
espèce de vieux débris j'aimerais voir
le patron de cet endroit c'est moi le
seul et unique patron veut devriez
savoir qu'un prêteur sur gages travaille
toujours seul à vraiment vous êtes seul
mais qu'est ce que vous faites
il n'y ait pas de vous servir de bonne
trame et donnez moi le contenu de la
caisse
non je vous en prie arrêtez alors donnez
moi tout de suite cet argent où je vous
descend et je l'emportent de toute façon
n'ont marqué
ce que nous venons voleurs et des mois
ça va vous n'avez rien non non tout va
bien je n'ai rien mais heureusement que
mes hommes étaient là pour tout arranger
venez voir comment ça vaut un homme
alors c'est vous les hommes du prêteur
sur gages
vous même dire lequel de vous deux à
tirer c'est moi tenez regardez ma balle
l'atteint ici est la mienne la tra là
je ne vous ai jamais vu ici quel est
votre nom désolé ça vous regarde pas
dites moi au moins d'où vous venez d
année je n'ai rien à dire très bien
comme vous voudrez en attendant creusé
un trou et enterré moi ce type
vous plaisantez et l'ami vous m'avez
sauvé la vie du vous êtes habile avec
les armes
ouais approché je voudrais vous proposer
une petite affaire
si vous acceptez de vous passer de cette
espèce de la boucle je vous engage tout
de suite comme garde du corps et bien
entendu vous serez lee thomas j ouais
pourquoi pas donnez moi le temps d'y
réfléchir
j'ai l'impression que les gens d'ici
sont vraiment son coeur et regarde ça
t'as vu ce nabot qui est en train de
creuser la fosse tu crois pas que c'est
un gamin plus tôt non tu veux rire
obtient va bien on n'a jamais vu un
enfant avec une tête de vieux nom ne
bouge pas tu les as entendu
oui mais c'est pas le moment de nous
faire remarquer alors laisse tomber tu
as sans doute raison
d'autant plus que je resterai bienvenus
s'ils ces deux villes est plutôt
chouette c'est bourré de saloon et dites
donc vous ne vous pourriez pas à les
creuser ailleurs une tombe devant mon
saloon ça va faire péricliter mes
affaires salut les gars à bientôt je
suis sûr qu'on soit vers un jour ou
l'autre à mon avis sont pas nets ces
deux là surtout le nabot il ressent pas
un être humain qu'à raison ça me demande
où ils sortent
ouais on voit tant de choses franck est
ce que nous allons devenir avec ce genre
d'énergumène en ville ce sont des
vagabonds peut-être même des bandits on
devrait s'en débarrasser
[Musique]
oh là là j'en ai assez dis moi pourquoi
c'était notre année c'est faux
tiens c'est bizarre jeune femme en train
d'observer way est ce qu'elle est jolie
je connais patego à mon avis oui est-ce
qu'à te retourne et lumière à toi même
oui en effet les ravissantes tu crois
que c'est une parente du mort si tu veux
le savoir quelqu'un lui demander
pourquoi ça serait pas toi curé l'avoir
trop tard a vécu là bas qu'est ce qu'on
fait ça écoute le prêteur n'en a pas
voulu
le propriétaire est mort ce fusil et
donc à nous regarde voilà notre client
qui entre puisqu'on a été embauché comme
garde du corps notre place est à
l'intérieur
qu'est ce que tu attends tu m'aimes les
données c'est 500 dollars annie dépêche
toi ou je te fais sauter la cervelle le
site inutile de vous fâcher
je vais vous les donner je vais vous les
donner bon maintenant ça suffit dégagez
vous allez bien battre on vient de
casser l'espèce de pauvres imbéciles
pourquoi avoir tué ces gars parce que je
n'ai entendu vous menacez de vous tuer
c'était un voleur on voit crétins cet
homme était un client nous étions en
train de nous mettre d'accord sur le
prix
il venait mettre en gage ces deux femmes
je me réjouissais de conclure cette
bonne affaire et tu as tout fait rater
sombre crétin
pourquoi tu tirais sans poser de
questions s'est désolé j'ai la gâchette
facile
disparaissez je ne veux plus vous voir
vous êtes viré d'accord mais vous devez
nous payer ou payer non mais vous voulez
rire
vous m'avez apporté que des ennuis non
voilà où on en est
la prochaine fois j'espère que tu
réfléchiras un peu avant de dégainer
je suis désolé bonsoir on avait trouvé
un bon boulot et toi tu nous fait mettre
à la porte
à l'avenir je t'interdis de tirer sans
avoir ma permission je suis d'accord
mais comme dans tout marché honnête il y
à des conditions désormais une bois
qu'avec ma permission qui est à dire
mais bon j'accepte et vous ne pouvez
venir dans mon bureau j'ai quelque chose
à vous dire attendez je vous expliquais
c'était de l'accident c'était un cas de
force majeure c'était de la légitime
défense ou ferment la ste play tétouan
venez pour vous ça alors c'est de
l'argent
on touche de l'argent sur les gens dans
cette ville j'avoue que je trouve cette
coutume surprenante l'homme que vous
avez tué était un criminel recherché
depuis très longtemps
sa tête était mise à prix à 30 dollars
moi je vois mais celui ci n'est que le
premier que nous avons tué bien que je
ne vois pas sa photo combien l'on nous
toucher pour le deuxième
attendez je ne vous comprends pas vous
en avez tué et un deuxième bar et
tétouan surtout ne dis rien je ne
m'attendais pas à voir autant d'argent
qu'est ce qu'on va en faire tant va
aller se restaurer c'est une bonne idée
vous avez l'air d'être de très bons
copains tous les deux oui c'est exact on
s'entend parfaitement bien en voyage
ensemble depuis très longtemps
pourquoi vous ne regardez comme ça pour
rien du tout je vous regarde comme j'en
ai envie
c'est le pays de la liberté sinon fiche
mais la paix ne t'approche pas de moi
n'avait pas la moindre envie non mais
qu'est ce qu'ils croient je suis assez
grand pour me débrouiller tout seul vous
en être certain le prêteur sur gages les
a jetés dehors tous les deux oui
monsieur le maire et à part les 30
dollars de la récompense ils sont
totalement sans ressources
parfait on va bientôt pouvoir les
considérer comme des vagabonds voire à
la limite des malfaiteurs
oui et j'ai reçu des informations de
source sûre il paraît qu'on les a vu
rôder en ville ça risque d'effrayer la
population mais c'est excellent pour
nous tous à nous allons pouvoir écourter
leur présence dans notre belle cité
faites ce que vous voulez mais qu'il
disparaisse monsieur le maire je crois
que j'ai exactement ce qu'il vous faut
qu'est ce qu'ils font là je croyais
partie bon je boirai la même chose et
préparés nous aussi quelque chose à
manger quoi qu'est-ce que vous avez on a
de quoi payer on est de vrais clients
santé ça fait longtemps que j'avais pas
vu un bonbon comme celui là on ira
remercier le gars qu'on a enterré tout
ça c'est grâce à lui bah qu'est ce que
tu as
[Musique]
c'est la fille de tout à l'heure quelle
mouche vie il faut qu'on reste sur nos
gardes en scylla mais non ne craint rien
départ mais ça se voit en tout cas elle
est bien roulé à mon avis l an après toi
et pour quelles raisons ils m'ont
voudrait l'homme qu'elle aimait été tué
pratiquement sous ses yeux est celui qui
l'a tout est installé au bar et en plus
ils boivent être l'agent de la
récompense c'est affreux tu allé
m'excuser je suis désolé veuillez
accepter ce fusil vous aidera peut-être
à me pardonner
je suis moi aussi désolé de ce qui est
arrivé
veuillez accepter toute notre fortune en
espérant que vous dénigrez nous
pardonner désolé ma jolie mais ceux-ci
m'appartient ces deux lascars sont
partis sans payer
vous avez entendu ils ont abandonné leur
fortune tu parles d'une fortune il
n'avait que 30 dollars ce qui compte
avant tout c'est le geste je suis
certaine que s'il avait eu des millions
de dollars il aurait agi exactement de
la même façon
qu'est ce que tu racontes ces deux
hommes sont capables d'abandonner le peu
qu'ils ont de se retrouver sans rire
c'est pour moi la preuve d'une grande
force
ras de terre
[Musique]
je suis mordu fin tu n'as qu'à t'en
prendre qu'à toi même tu n'étais pas
obligé de lui donner tout notre argent
inutile de remuer le couteau dans la
plaie ça ne change rien alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait je crois que nous n'avons pas
tellement le choix on n'est pas les
bienvenus dans cette ville le mieux
serait d'aller voir ailleurs
ouais mais si on veut poursuivre notre
chemin il va nous falloir quelques
provisions et je ne sais pas où nous
allons en trouver tiens voilà encore
cette femme elle va chez le prêteur avec
larmes que je lui ai donné on dirait
qu'elle a fait affaire avec lui
combien se gagne escroc vous est il à
faire cinq malheureux ce n est pas du
tout 500 dollars voire 500 dollars ce
type est un escroc doublé d'un obsédé
regarde
j'en étais sûr il la revend le double de
ce qu'il a payé
quel radin quelle salle arnaqueurs s'il
avait accepté payer cette somme l'autre
jour au premier voyageur ce pauvre homme
n'aurait pas tenté de le voler c'est
vrai peut-être bien qu'oui ou peut-être
bien tu n'es rien n'est jamais certain
dans la vie et quand arrive le résultat
quoi qu'on ait faire on n'est jamais
content et on se dira si j'avais fait
comme si au lieu de faire comme ça ou
alors si c'est comme ça à mieux vaut
faire comme ça ou si j'avais fait ça
j'aurais peut-être commis ça et que tu
pourrais être serait ce qu'une seconde
arrêté ton insignifiant par le temps
[Musique]
tu les reconnaît ce sont des deux filles
qui étaient chez twitter j'ai
l'impression qu'elles ont engagé des
tueurs contre l'eau moi je me taille
reste lazio ne crains rien je vais me
charger je te signale que sont deux pas
de problème
[Musique]
où
et
[Musique]
a maintenant un problème je te rappelle
que tu dois me donner la permission
tirer espèce d'imbécile dans un cas
pareil il faut tirer
bon si tu le dis si bien joué c'est
vraiment le meilleur
je crois que j'ai bien fait de garder ce
pistolet non je croyais que nous étions
vos ennemis pourquoi nous avoir sauvé la
vie
oui je sais bien disons qu'il me restait
des balles alors je les ai utilisés
non en fait j'ai senti que l'heure de
votre mort n'avait pas encore sonné ne
me demandez pas pourquoi c'est ainsi
encore vous devriez poursuivre ces deux
femmes sinon elles vont recommencer
croyez moi je sais de quoi je parle
expliqué mots je n'ai rien de plus à
vous dire sinon que vous devez vous
méfier faites ce que vous voudrez mais
qui êtes vous que savez-vous en réalité
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui se passe encore sedif et
ça pour moi je te promets qu'ils
rencontrent
je te fais mes promesses situe
l'étudiante et drate moi tout ce que tu
désires mais qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que ces deux femmes fabriquent
ici regardons silence espèces
d'andouille qu'est ce que je vous avais
dit j'espère que maintenant vous avez
compris voilà le moyen qu'elles ont
trouvée pour inciter ses hommes à vous
tuer
je dois avouer qu'elles ont des
arguments plutôt convaincant si vous ne
faites rien pour vous en débarrassez
vous serez harcelés par leurs tueurs
quoi que vous fassiez où que vous alliez
c'est à vous de décider que je ne peux
pas me résoudre à tuer des femmes qui
plus est c'est nous qui avons assassiné
l'homme qui les accompagner chez le
prêteur sur gages nous l'avions pris
pour un voleur mais je dois faire
quelque chose
j'y vais il paraît que vous me chercher
pour me tuer alors me voilà qu'est ce
que vous attendez
oh non c'est vrai je vous attends
habillez vous mettez vos ceintures on a
retrouvé mois de hors jeu n'est pas
toute la journée
la prochaine fois je vise le coeur très
bien très bien j'ai compris oui moi
aussi je moi je crois qu'ils ont compris
vous les avez effrayer qu'est ce que
vous comptez faire de ces deux femmes
rien c'est pas mon problème il est grand
tort de quitter cette ville cette
histoire est terminée que nous n'avons
plus rien à faire ici
mais avec ces deux familles avec vous ça
c'est ce que vous croyez
[Musique]
encore vous comment se retrouve
maintenant dites moi ce qui s'est passé
j'irai sur ces deux hommes mais c'était
juste pour leur faire peur ces deux
femmes nous avait séduits pour les
pousser à nous tuer bien nous allons
voir ça mais en attendant remettez moi
votre arme c'est vraiment une arme
magnifique
vous êtes fois vous les avez tué
non je suis vraiment désolé c'est idiot
je crois que les coups sont partis tout
seul les mains en l'air vous êtes en
état d'arrestation pour homicides
volontaires sur deux pauvres femmes sans
défense je ne pouvais pas faire ça
nous avons plusieurs mois quant à vous
deux vous n'en avez pas assez de vous
faire humilier
elle est rhabillé vous oui shérif oui
chérif espèce d'idiot tu n'as pas encore
compris que ces hommes sont assez
sombres
alors qu'est ce qu'on va devenir j'ai
mis au point une politique très efficace
pour nettoyer cette ville
il suffit de faire se rencontrer tous
les bandits et les indésirables et de
les laisser s'entretuer
je suis le maire de cette paisible cité
et qui plus est un ardent défenseur de
l'ordre de la paix et tous les moyens
sont bons
et moi j'ai énormément d'influx ans dans
cette ville rendez-moi la récompense que
je vous avait attribué à tort nous avons
déjà tout dépensé il y à une autre loi
en vigueur dans cette ville qui interdit
à tout individu sans domicile fixe de
recevoir une aide ou une récompense de
la part des habitants ou des services de
la commune et de plus vous allez enfin
une autre loi fondamentale qui dit que
tout acte de violence est prohibé mais
ce sont eux qui ont tiré les premiers
ces sommes sont les gardiens et les
défenseurs de l'ordre public
en tant que représentants de la loi
qu'ils ont le devoir de porter une arme
et bien sûr de s'en servir vous par
contre vous n'en aviez pas le droit je
crois que nous devrions les pendre est
une excellente idée allons-y afin que
règne la paix et d'harmonie taille douce
ne poussez pas
quand je pense que depuis le début le
prêteur sur gages et les shérifs sans
complice nous n'en sortirons pas
vivement tout ici n'est que corruption
des gens comme eux ne devraient pas
exister il ne mérite qu'une seule chose
mourir
ah non mourir aaa a tu sais que tu es un
petit marrant toi j'espère que vous avez
tous entendu ce que raconte cette espèce
de nabot à lunettes à l'ehess série
avance dépêche toi un peu non oh
vous avez vu leur début d'août vient
cette arme
ce n'est pas un sabre ordinaire mes
mains sont beaucoup trop petit pour me
permettre de tenir correctement un
pistolet cette arme me convient beaucoup
mieux
ah oui mais tu n'est pourtant pas un
indien que je sache en quoi cela porte à
ses vrais toshirô n'est ni un indien ni
d'ailleurs à blanc c'est tout simplement
mon meilleur ami et sans lui je ne
serais pas envie aujourd'hui
maintenant vous avez intérêt à cesser de
nous suivre
si vous tenez à rester en vie allez
allez au revoir à l'approché rhénane
séjour
à ton avis est-ce qu'on a bien agir en
la laissant tout seul dans cet endroit
n'en sais rien pas de regret toute façon
c'est trop tard ouais tu as raison tu
sais chacun son destin en a certains qui
meurt et d'autres qui réussissent à
survivre bien maintenant si on penser un
peu à nous et à ce qu'on va faire les
jours qui viennent ouais c'est une
excellente idée mais je te rappelle que
j'ai toujours aussi faim
qu'est-ce que vous fabriquez là j'ai
brusquement décidé de vous accompagner
c'est impossible nous ne pouvons en mai
personne ma décision est prise je
n'avais rien à dire je viens avec vous
que vous vouliez ou non
bien alors je me présente westerners
franklin albator junior et moi je
m'appelle touchions enchanté et moi
c'est si moon aura pour éviter qu'il y
ait des conflits entre nous on n'a qu'à
prétendre que je suis un garçon
cependant parfois il m'arrivera de
laisser transparaître ma féminité gun
frontier le combat de l'homme pour sa
liberté
l'histoire d'une balade solitaire et
mélancolique gun frontier
un nom qui pour l'homme est synonyme de
tristesse et qui ne se prononcent
qu'avec les larmes aux yeux
est ce la poussière qui appelle la
tempête ou est ce la tempête qui appelle
la poussière dans cet endroit c'est
inutile d'y réfléchir car nous sommes à
cannes frontières
[Musique]
maga
je
key
[Musique]
tous
non
[Musique]